[Applause]
[Music]
australia
and south korea what could these two
countries which are more than 6 000
kilometers apart
that's 3 700 miles possibly have in
common okay
for many the answer may seem obvious the
superpower after all both south korea
and australia are two strategic allies
of the united states
two key alliances for washington two
essential allies for the influence of
the american giant in the asia pacific
region a region that has already become
the main hub
of the world economic activity
[Music]
of course that's not the only thing they
have in common in the korean war the
australians fought side by side with the
south koreans to stop the invasion
launched by the communist regime in
north korea an invasion which by the way
was supported by more than a million
chinese soldiers but since then these
two countries have been part of the
political
economic and military bloc led by the
united states of america
however over the last two decades the
arrival of a new political player has
revealed huge cracks in the relationship
between these two countries i am
referring of course to the people's
republic of china
china's growing economic political and
even military influence is changing
everything in this region of the world
and it is here that we can ask ourselves
exactly the same question that hammers
insistently in the minds of many of the
world's top political leaders how on
earth
should we deal with china well there is
no single answer and the emergence of
china as a superpower is breaking down
homogeneous foreign policy models
in fact australia and south korea are
two good examples they are two countries
that for decades belong to the same
block but have now started to follow
quite different paths in the way they
deal with china a separation that
nevertheless has its limits because
let's not fool ourselves
the truth is that both south koreans and
australians have their hands and feet
tied to a large extent
wait a minute what why well let's take a
look
approximately 30 percent of australian
exports are destined for the chinese
giant a percentage even higher than
south korea's 25
in addition the chinese also represent
the bulk of australia's tourists in the
case of south korea during 2019
that is pre-coronavirus 6 million
chinese people
visited the country which is almost 35
percent of the total in the case of
australia we are talking about almost
1.5 million chinese tourists and
exactly the same goes for foreign
investment the market share of the asian
giant
is on the rise
yes there are those who describe all
this as a growing economic dependence
and whether or not this is so you can't
deny that this type of thing generally
has a strong influence on a country's
foreign policy of course it is one thing
to have influence and quite another to
determine policy
australia china ties are at their lowest
point in history
former ambassador says abc news
australia despite the fact that china
has already become australia's largest
trading partner the country of aussies
koalas and kangaroos has remained
closely aligned with washington's
interests in the region
a very different strategy from the one
followed by south korea precisely
because of this
we are going to see in this video
exactly how these two countries which
remain key allies of the united states
have followed very different paths with
respect to china and the question is
which position would you back
listen up
[Music]
no consideration for beijing
let's see if we had been asked just a
few years ago for a western country that
was going to get along badly
diabolically badly with china from
around 2019
i'm sure australia would have been our
last choice we are talking about a
country of barely 25 million inhabitants
which is also home to 1.2 million people
of chinese origin and one which
regularly welcomes thousands of students
and great fortunes from the asian giant
a country that maintains such close
economic relations with the people's
republic of china that many analysts do
not hesitate to qualify them as
wildly dependent however despite this
since 2011 when barack obama included
this country in the so-called american
pivot to asia in a speech in the
australian parliament relations between
the united states and australia
historically the bffs of international
politics have experienced a second
honeymoon
an example of this in the development in
northern australia of two important
staging areas for the united states air
force and the us navy in the pacific
and believe me when i tell you that
these are the kind of moves that beijing
doesn't like
one bit
the point is that these reservations
towards the extending of chinese
tentacles are growing amongst the
aussies and they are no longer amused by
chinese companies taking over strategic
assets on australian soil
transactions such as the 2015 lease of
the port of darwin to the chinese
company landbridge group for a term of
99 years in exchange for 380 million
dollars
are now seen as a threat to national
security
[Music]
and it's clear that chinese companies
seem obsessed with taking control of key
infrastructure in australia along with
the scandals involving australian
politicians and businessmen with
suspicious ties to the chinese
government and the arrival of trump to
power formed an explosive cocktail that
multiplied the distrust and reservations
of australians towards china as a result
virtually any moderately significant
chinese investment in the country is
subject to intense political and social
scrutiny
[Music]
in fact things have gotten so bad that
during 2020 and early 2021 we have even
seen a trade brawl of sorts between
australia and china a clash
in which we have seen tariffs levies
boycotts and even smear campaigns in the
form of tweets and montages
yes it's a very lively story almost like
a latin american soap opera but do you
want some more concrete examples
well take a look china formalizes cut to
australian coal imports
state media reports the guardian
china slaps up to 200 tariffs on
australian wine
bbc australia takes china to wto over
barley tariffs
beijing imposed tariffs of 80 on the
crop after bilateral relations
deteriorated financial times
of course all these how should i put it
punishments have nothing to do with
commercial problems but with political
ones because the truth is that the
relationship between beijing and
canberra during 2020 was particularly
tense
[Music]
you see during 2020 the australian
government was one of the most critical
of xi jinping's policy regarding the
coronavirus pandemic the australian
government
actively advocated that china should be
required to agree to an international
commission of inquiry to discover the
true origins of the tsar's coronavirus
ii
and if necessary to hold the country
accountable then regarding the events in
hong kong the australian government was
also particularly critical of beijing's
assault on power
in the city and as if that were not
enough of a declaration of intent
australia continued its policy of
opposing the deployment of 5g networks
by chinese companies such as huawei
which had been banned on australian
territory and to top it off it has also
condemned the chinese government's
construction of artificial islands in
the south china sea
but wait a minute because the squabbles
between the two countries do not end
there
check it out australia china relations
hit
rock bottom after provocative tweet by
senior communist party official global
voices
check out this tweet in it a senior
chinese foreign minister official posted
a photo montage allegedly of an
australian soldier holding a bloody
knife in his hand and who was about to
cut the throat of an afghan boy with a
lamb in his arms
now you have to be twisted the message
reads as follows
shocked by murder of afghan civilians
and prisoners by australian soldiers we
strongly condemn such acts
and call for holding them accountable li
jian zhao
deputy director of foreign ministry
information department of the people's
republic of china
the tweet as you can imagine raised
hackles at all levels of australian
politics
[Music]
anyway as you can see relations between
beijing and canberra are going through
quite a bit of a rough patch and this
despite the fact that the two countries
have just joined the new regional
comprehensive economic partnership
agreement which integrates 15 countries
in the region and which we have already
mentioned in another video the point is
that all of these rifts have led
australians to have a very poor opinion
of the land of the sleeping giant to
give you an example
according to an october 2020 study by
pew research 81
of australians have a bad image of china
and 79
do not trust that xi jinping has good
intentions with his international policy
so there you have it australia does
indeed have very close economic
relations with china but
despite this its government has clearly
decided to align itself with the united
states
stand up for the political concept of
the west and actively denounce any and
all excesses perpetrated by xi jinping's
government let's see how long it lasts
but so far their strategy could not have
been more different from that followed
by the european union or countries such
as
south korea for example where pragmatism
has completely won the day
over idealism listen up
[Music]
south korea's fragile balancing act
if we take a look at the relations
between south korea and china what we
find is a very mixed bag
the current asian titan has gone from
being an avowed enemy of south korea
during the korean war and the following
three decades to becoming its main
trading partner
and source of tourists it is also a key
player indispensable and necessary for
stability on the peninsula due to the
special relationship that exists between
beijing and pyongyang so believe me when
i tell you that in the corridors of the
blue house which
is the south korean equivalent of the
white house when it comes to china they
are convinced that it is better to look
the other way
and to risk triggering a political and
perhaps commercial conflict that could
be very damaging for south korea and
don't think that this is just
speculation south korea already got a
taste of what chinese anger is all about
just a few years ago
china inflicted a world of pain on south
korea in 2017
courts the reason
well during 2017 the tensions were
running high on the korean peninsula due
to north korean
intercontinental missile tests and the
united states deployed the thaad
terminal high altitude area defense
missile shield in south korea with
seoul's approval
at that point china became angry it
believed that the powerful u.s radars
would be able to track each and every
movement of its army on the east coast
of china so in response
beijing launched a massive boycott
against south korea suddenly the chinese
stopped consuming south korean products
chinese tourism in south korea came to a
screeching halt and many local
businesses suffered losses in the
millions even to the point of requiring
financial assistance from the government
many korean companies doing business in
china were also persecuted and coerced
especially those of the lot group which
owns the golf course that was made
available to install the thud
there were also violent attacks on
korean branded cars
and take note because although the
installation of fard in south korea was
approved by former president park
geun-hye its installation took place
when moon jae-in was president and not
only did he stop it but he authorized
each and every one of the arrivals of
new batteries and radars that is as far
as it goes
that is practically the end of the moon
government's history of confrontation
with china since then its strategy
towards the asian giant has taken a very
different course give you some examples
and to compare it with the australian
position we discussed earlier the south
korean government said absolutely
nothing about the chinese assault on
hong kong
nor have they said a word about the
management or alleged origin of the
coronavirus pandemic in china prevented
huawei from deploying 5g networks in the
country or criticized the construction
of artificial islands in the south china
sea and not only that korea
has kept a low profile on the entire u.s
china trade war issue during trump's
presidency and has never gone so far as
to comment against
any foreign policy of the asian giant
beyond the typical
we are very concerned about the
situation now the question is what
explains this equidistance
is south korea not one of the united
states closest allies in the world and
their main ally in east asia well
yes but in the case of south korea there
are more factors that come into play and
that must be taken care of at all costs
at least that's what moon jae-in's
government thinks
[Music]
the problem if we can call it that is
that almost all major south korean
conglomerates not only do huge business
in the chinese market but they also have
many of their production plants there
too and although in recent years some
manufacturers such as samsung hyundai
and lg have tried to reduce their
manufacturing dependency on china by
setting up factories in other countries
such as vietnam the truth is that the
dependence on china when it comes to
manufacturing south korean products
is enormous
[Music]
or in other words seoul is certain that
angering beijing could trigger xi
jinping's regime to impose tariffs and
restrictions on south korea similar to
or even worse than the punishments it
has already imposed on australia what
they believe could put the global
business of major korean companies at
risk and that
is a big risk but wait a minute because
it's not that simple the south korean
government is caught between
three variables that are difficult to
rebalance the economy its alliance with
the united states of america
and public opinion you see just like in
australia south koreans don't exactly
think highly of china or xi jinping
according to the polls only four percent
of south koreans believe that their
country should prioritize relations with
china over the united states and only 17
believe there should be equidistance
with china and the united states which
is basically the current policy of the
moon jain government
moreover according to poles 83 of south
koreans have a negative opinion of xi
jinping and 76
have a negative image of china as a
country
[Music]
and as you can see in south korea's case
the government has decided to follow a
completely different strategy from that
of australian prime minister
scott morrison and so we come back to
the question that i asked you at the
beginning of this video
which position do you think is better
should we prioritize economic pragmatism
when dealing with
china which is the policy that south
korea is following or do you think that
western democracies should call out the
chinese government as australia has been
doing in recent years
leave your answers down in the comments
below so i really hope you enjoyed this
video please hit like if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and hear some more of
my lovely voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher